hello everybody and welcome to part 4 of
amnesia the Dark Descent I'm about to
make my way and mix up some chemicals
just slosh them in a pickle ah [ __ ]
bucket not a [ __ ] bucket big ol bucket
and see what happens
I remember reading something about it
being dangerously corrosive and letter
it can't be that bad
sea of gibraltar SS Hortensia headed for
London s where Daniels from Mayfair okay
so for God right no monsters came in
since I left everything is as it should
be who's there no one that's good
alright should you be a oh yeah oh yeah
I barely touched the thing he's forgot
let a bomb off which I might be doing
later but not now right go yeah
oh yeah yep
oh [ __ ]
ah the cup hot okay I got it right there
we go
all right take two you didn't see
anything
burners turn on the green purple little
red little pink mauve ah that's it
just what I need man taking some of this
cannabis right now
ain't no thang ah ah ah come on and once
again my torches got extinguished [ __ ]
it's why they got so many damn
tinderboxes laying around everywhere
they put out your torches gimme na ah
smart dumb dumb ah smart smart smart
smart smart whoo yeah I got my pot of
acid because honestly who doesn't need a
good pot of acid
it's everywhere oh can I use it on this
store does the store lead outside yes I
am smart oh I am smart all right I'll do
it the dumb way
fine
yay
moving forward to the refinery finery
sounds fiery I wonder if there's an
allegory to going in the depths of hell
I don't think I used allegory correctly
don't judge me
not an English major this looks good
I like this okay
it sure is dark in here yes and there's
a good reason for it but you can light
the lamp now if you wish what's the
reason for darkness that is stay close
be careful not to stray what's the
reason why is it so dark
why is a day of tension dandle it's
important that you keep going straight
and make sure not to stray oh oh I'm
straying oops
and he's put bring it on I'm not scared
not even a little bit okay I'm scared
I'm scared ah just kidding nose yeah
yeah no biggie freedom
just another whale call close oh shut up
Daniel lucky I'm here
I have a little safe room I can come to
and be safe I'm sure oh here's some rope
I can climb out that hole in the ceiling
all right
you have anybody there
OOP okay I don't two candles oh hey
y'all
ah don't even try it
22nd of June 1839 it's been more than a
month since my last entry after the
event inside the underground chamber in
Algeria uh-huh as a Herbert insisted I
were burned in me said he drew out a
risk forfeiting the entire expedition
lest I took a turn for the worse an
excessive decision her respect but I'm
glad it turned out that way I'm getting
the idea of my Daniel is mentally how an
election of things were at least honest
table next to it yeah lay the broken
stone all wrapped in cloth and try to
assemble it but couldn't the pieces
wouldn't fit together a little that
impossible geometry going on there
I am imagined it all yes was there ever
a complete or no yeah
imagine in crap so much crap of all you
guys are done not you guys not my fuse
you guys who the smartest of y'all oil
what have we got in here a little
trapdoor action too heavy to lift
for me Oh impossibruuu
could it be this stick baby
wow that was a hard puzzle tinderbox in
the box in the box huh all right I
suppose I can move on
am i moving too fast for this game
ooh daylight like daylight Oh
what what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that what the
[ __ ] oh
what is it I do not appreciate the music
ah
is it still there ah oh my god what do I
do
ah okay okay alright
all right I am calm jump
Oh
learn away in that room I'll be golden
yeah
I can't touch this yeah strike get out
ah
oh you don't know this
oh no not a time thing not a time thing
oh-ah oh-ah we go what do I do
I'm too smart I'm too smart ha ha ha
[ __ ] yeah oh I've seen this porn yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah
ah
yea-ah oil desires
oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] me go oh my god Wow Wow Wow I go
eat go eat eat who's over there care of
something big
yeah just pour so Oh over there that's a
good water monster
yeah yeah oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh the music still going oh that's just
a normal splash well got him out here
okay all right
ah yeah yeah yeah wasn't scared huh yeah
yeah nothing yeah yep yeah I'm just
gonna offer on more water
no no oh give me some of this hang on
my god oh god oh god ah ha ha [ __ ] yeah
now
yeah then nothing
I'm obviously the best
need to deal with it
yeah [ __ ] hahahahaha oh yeah I'm
obviously totally manly oh can deal with
stressful situations without panic
I'm gonna go benchpress an elephant or
something
all right I have to stop it there oh my
god my heart uh uh I think that's it for
tonight I'm going to pick this up
tomorrow though stay tuned for part five
and thanks for watching guys